of the players underperforming I think
with the new coach
the new coach came from where
he was
I was in IX also
IX is a talented Club they have the best
talents in the club
they don't have big stars
what is the experience of this coach
young talents he comes to United United
is different mentality different players
so the players there
supposed to be big stars
so I think with his experience being
there I don't know if it talks for him
or not because he I think he's in a
different situation and then above him
there is a gap where he doesn't get the
help to manage the team listen this is
what I read in the paper so it's not I
have
all the situations that that is
happening but I can just imagine him
coming from my ex to to United is a big
difference because I've been in both
clubs
you manage Talent up growing is
different kind of approach because
there you have a different kind of
discipline you come to United you you do
the same thing I don't know I don't
believe and I don't think it's the same
treatment you give I mean Cristiano
Ronaldo when he gave the interview to me
when he left United he said that he felt
he didn't have the respect of Eric ten
Hogg you see with Jaden Sancho now a
similar situation 10 how criticizing him
in public and so on maybe that is an
illustration of his of his problems in
managing big Talent
but I don't
I don't say it's the coach fault because
experience you cannot buy you just have
to get time to get the experience but
it's too different situations being in
IX being united then if it's his fault I
don't think because I think everybody
has a responsible in the whole situation
we are a piece of puzzle from the big
puzzle so everybody have a
responsibility to do and to
to fulfill the the the demands United
has to win they
they have to win every title they play
for now they're being dominating by the
neighbors and
and it's a totally different situation
there and you need to find the right
path again and to to push for that now
it's
I think it's you need a plan you need a
project to follow and it feels like you
follow a project plan and then it goes
wild in a moment because of the results
either you believe in it or you don't
believe in it so but with the situation
of the coach I think he's living two
different situations now
then obviously what happened with santro
and and Christian I don't know because
is he do you think he's out of his depth
a bit ten hug
I think he needs more time to get the
experience how to handle a team but you
don't really get time at a club like not
obviously not because we need to win
that's the reality you come to my
when I was in Milan I cannot give you
time to to develop to to to perform you
need to perform straight because like I
said survival mode it's you or another
one because United is in a situation you
don't do good enough the next day there
is another one and the result speaks for
itself so that's why the It's Tricky but
how much time do you give a quote I
don't know depends of the owners what
they want but if you listen to the fans
you don't have a lot of time because
they want to win absolutely and I
understand them because
they're used to win and they want to
still win so
I think it's a lot of things the small
details often makes the difference it's
not the the whole the big pictures you
see because when things are good
they were there are still errors and
problems but you don't see it because we
are winning